on n'a pas vu autant de troupes russes
massés à la frontière de l'ukraine
depuis l'annexion de la crimée en 2014
des vidéos captées dans les régions
limitrophes montre des chars et des
armes lourdes traverser les villages il
y aurait plus de cinquante mille soldats
russes posté près des zones rebelles pro
russe et le déploiement continu et fioul
risque vis briques même si on edge of
our ill l'analyste militaire alexander
golts parle d'un risque énorme dans
cette poudrière de l'europe 1500 km de
frontières ou depuis sept ans déjà les
rebelle pro-russe affrontent l'armée
ukrainienne
et c'est là au front dans les tranchées
même que le président de l'ukraine vole
du maire hélène ce qui s'est rendu
vendredi pour plaider sa cause avec un
journaliste du réseau social
il nous faut plus que des mots a dit
zelensky qui veut joindre les rangs de
l'otan car dans l'éventualité d'une
guerre l'ukraine n'aurait aucune chance
à l'armée russe dit l'analyste
wood gundy fight for you babe à tokyo
est ce bien malgré l'aide financière des
états unis de l'europe
rosewall et des pays comme le canada qui
comme on voit ici en train les soldats
kiev depuis des années d'où la nécessité
de négocier la paix a dit le président
turc acquise hélène ce qui rend des
visites durant le week-end interrogé sur
ses motivations sur le pourquoi d'un tel
déploiement
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov a répondu
froidement
c'est notre pays et on fait ce qu'on
veut si la russie prétend tout de même
que son déploiement militaire n'est
qu'un simple exercice son ampleur
inédite ne cache pas le potentiel de
déstabiliser l'ordre mondial
roche bellini si ce genre de diplomatie
brutale pour but de tester joba eden et
les membres de l'otan l'exercice est
périlleux avec des tonnes de munitions à
portée de main de deux armés qui sèment
des [ __ ] depuis des années la moindre
provocation pourrait déclencher une
guerre officiel entre l'ukraine et la
russie moscou pour l'instant fait la
sourde oreille
mais le temps lui suggère de reculer et
de le faire rapidement
si thammarat intéresse qu radio-canada
moscou